in this video I want to talk about
g-protein coupled receptors and second
messengers and a very general idea and
it's sort of general scheme of it so we
have a hormone it's a polar hormone it's
going to bind on the cell surface of a
particular receptor that receptor is
right here drawn in purple now since
we're talking about g-protein coupled
receptors this purple protein here is
specifically the g-protein coupled
receptor gpcr now why is it called that
well because attached to this g-protein
coupled receptor is this thing which is
AG protein now this G protein has three
subunits the Alpha subunit beta subunit
and gamma subunit and initially it has a
GDP attached to its alpha subunit and
that's because it's in an inactive State
how do we activate it
well that's when this hormone comes in
so the hormone comes in and binds this
receptor that is specific for that
binding event triggers a conformational
change in this g-protein coupled
receptor that conformational change
triggers the activation of this
g-protein how does that actually happen
well a gtp is comes in and replaces that
GDP and the alpha subunit of the G
protein leaves and travels down the
membrane towards this thing here so this
is a G off a subunit and it has instead
of having a GDP it now has a gtp
attached to it so now it is active and
when it's active it goes over to this
blue thing here that I've drawn and it's
embedded in the membrane this thing is
called an effector enzyme now for
different g-protein coupled receptor
Cascades the effector and effector
enzyme excuse me I put effect enzyme
effector enzyme might be different but
essentially what's supposed to happen is
that once this G alpha subunit that's
activated once it's a
attached or interacting with this
effector enzyme it'll activate this
effector enzyme in addition these two
subunits by the way of the g-protein
stay back with this g-protein coupled
receptor so once this effector enzyme is
active what it does is it creates second
messengers so second message a second
messenger or second messengers now those
things trigger a certain cellular
response and that's the general scheme
of a g-protein coupled receptor it's a
little bit different from four different
Cascades but what sort of examples are
there of different second messengers one
really really common one is cyclic GMP
CA MP another that we're going to talk
about later is ip3 and daj will talk
about the pathways that these guys are
involved in in later videos I hope that
brief overview is helpful one last thing
I Owen Tudor if you live in Southern
California feel free to contact me via
email at move University at gmail.com
and see the description below for more
details
thanks for watching